first episode yeah we we were filming
the first day I remember her filming in
Venice it's crazy I mean Abel we kind of
had fun screwing around with the crew
and stuff you've never met before and I
remember a couple of the guys in fact
that the camera our focus puller Keith I
always give him a hard time because the
first day we were filming I was dead
serious and you know just being really
hardcore and I'm like don't ever look at
me and he was so freaked out and he
didn't realize I was completely full of
it just you know goofing on him but it's
funny to think back to the days when you
didn't know anybody was and now it's
become this big family did you ever
imagine I mean these shows are so
difficult because first you got to get
the pilot in your body then you got did
you ever imagine you get to 200 episodes
no I always thought if we could get to
100 episodes that would be pretty
amazing and you know sign me up if we
can do a show that goes 100 episodes and
that was a huge accomplishment I'm ever
standing in this room we had a cake
ceremony for the hundredth I was like
wow we got to 100 it feels like it has
been overnight that we've gotten to 200
and so it's and it's an amazing
accomplishment not many shows get to
that number and you're kind of in
rarified air
are you surprised you burned out because
the big thing is to stay fresh and in it
and burn it down
burned out here they wanted you said no
I haven't I haven't felt burned out I
mean I think there's different ways of
being burned out some guys I think get
burned up by the schedule yeah we've
been really fortunate that we keep a
really tight ship here and keep really
reasonable hours and manage that
effectively but you could also get
burned out of the character and playing
the role for me it's been
continues to be exciting and interesting
I mean you should it took me eight years
to find out what my first name was you
know it's it's one of those kind of
shows and there's constantly new
storylines and people coming in and out
of the characters lives and not to
mention we get you know crazy stunt
sequences that pop up every week you
know you read description like oh my
gosh how we're gonna do that but they
figure it out and we do it 200th episode
I'm sure the story is going to be
something special you know Kensi and
Deeks for a long time are they gonna get
married
eventually might it happen on the 200th
episode
I don't think so but I won't say no no I
mean it it's 200 B great episode it's
we're just coming off the season
premiere so it's pretty early in the
season but yeah we'll have to see if
they'll be wedding bells any time soon
there's lots of stuff in store season 9
is gonna be a good one tough one for you
obviously Sam going through a whirlwind
having lost you know his wife what does
that mean for your character heading
forward into this ninth season well I'm
looking out for my friend but at the
same time I'm we need him back on the
team we've got a lot going on we're
missing Hetty she's m.i.a
we don't know where she is you know all
the sudden there's a new assistant
director who's shipping dekes out of the
office you know there's a lot of things
going on and I need I need my partner
back night-long is incredible you know
people have grown up watching her all
the way from boys in the hood - now I'm
joining your cast what does that mean
because she is so experienced what does
that mean for the show and are you
excited to have her be a part of it yeah
it's great to have her it's always good
to have new blood new energy on the show
I think that it's you know always
challenging for people coming in when
this shows such a well-oiled machine and
there's this family that's so close and
all the sudden you're the new kid on the
block but I think she's fitting in great
and you know it offers a lot of
challenges for the characters in the
show they don't want somebody coming in
here and telling them what to do any
hazing I mean joining this cast you
already said you gave you know people
are tough I don't know that it was it's
been intentional but I suppose I suppose
you know sometimes when you reach a
milestone it's also a time of reflection
you know Miguel was obviously a big part
of the show do you ever think you think
about what it would have meant to him
getting - huh 200 absolutely I mean we
think I think we get all the time and it
was nice that they recognized him and
the the Emmy ceremony the other night
it's a big big moment for everybody and
we've lost you know crew members and
cast members and and we've had babies
born and people married and divorces and
it's you know it's a real family and you
share those experiences amongst the crew
and the cast and that's part of what
bonds us and brings us all together so I
think it's nice to take a day like this
to recognize our 200 200 episodes and
just acknowledge it because everyone
works real hard anyone getting gifts
usually any gift then you see all the
new Ferrari
yeah I thought about that as a cute as a
goof to put like a big fancy sports car
in front of my trailer with big bow on
it and then be like what you guys didn't
get one that would have been actually
yeah wrapping up here you know hillary
clinton said her post-election show was
NCIS bill also said that this is the
best of all the would you loved if they
were gonna be written into the show
what kind of plot line would you like to
see from i have no idea it's what i ran
into him at the Clinton at the Kennedy
Center Honors last year when I was there
and he came up to me and said that I was
like oh that's so nice of you to say I'm
thinking come on he says that to
everybody
I saw that you know in the book that she
says I'm like that's pretty funny he
actually is watching it's pretty amazing
so the people who watch the show yeah I
mean but I you know I get that all the
time whether you know doesn't know he's
presidents but people will pull you
aside and say hey man I just want too
much I like to show my god that's so
nice even they're like no no you don't
understand I I don't ever miss it and
and it's nice having fans that are that
passionate